das passt irgendwie überhaupt nicht
zusammen ich meine wir haben den polit
der ist oben total war und hier total
kalt dh man kann ihn nicht anziehen wenn
es kalt ist man kann ihn aber auch nicht
anziehen wenn es warm ist versteht ihr
was ich meine
[Musik]
hey leute was klappt und es willkommen
beim ein video ja leute ich hoffe ihr
habt mich gerade
ich habe keine ahnung ob das mikrofon
überhaupt anders oder spaß ich glaube
ich habe mittlerweile schon 400
youtube-videos und für dieses
youtube-video habe ich jetzt am
wenigsten zeit weil ich muss mich
megabyte ich habe noch genau nach genau
25 minuten und dann muss ich los weil
ich flieg nach london
wie heißt der flughafen keine ahnung
deswegen hoffe ich verspreche mich nicht
allzu oft ihr habt aber auch glück ich
werde am anfang nicht so viel haben wie
sonst immer damit ich am ende mehr zeit
haben und hinzu kommt ich muss jetzt
auch schnell essen das heißt ich habe
doch weniger als 25 minuten also wir
sehen uns gleich wieder hast du das
thema heute ist übrigens ich habe mir
vor einer woche ungefähr mädchen trends
2017 die jungs cool finden die ganz cool
sind oder die erhard kundinnen und mir
geschickt habt gemacht habe ich auch
wieder echte menge bekommen und es geht
halt um mädchen trends 2007 warum schon
wieder mich interessiert auch jungs
trends man kann ja stimmt das kommt auch
noch
ich komme also es geht halt um mädchen
trends von 2017 die nicht so cool sind
beziehungsweise die jungs hatten wobei
ich heute sagen kann dass fast mehr
mädchen mir sachen geschickt haben als
jungs die sie halt was du mädchen trends
eine total schrecklich finden und ich
habe mir mal so das lustigste geschrien
schadet und wir schauen uns das gleich
zusammen an jetzt muss ich aber erstmal
ist nun für den schnellen anfangen lässt
jetzt mal jeder daumen nach oben da war
das überhaupt nicht ob wir sind locken
schon wieder bei einer minute dreißig
kriegs einfach ein paar sekunden später
das wird nichts muss meinen kopf auch
noch
wir machen es natürlich immer ich zeige
euch das foto bleibt dass hier ein und
ihr könnt ja auch immer vielleicht in
den kommentaren mit schreiben feiert ihr
das oder nicht also wir schauen uns
jetzt mal an was ihr mir so einen
komischen mädchen trends 2017 geschickt
habe jeder hat so ein ding alter wir
machen die baby noch reicher als sie ist
schauen sie doch mal an die ist doch so
bescheuert hätte aber du hast ja selber
so was wie wie soll nicht reicher werden
als sie eh schon ist aber kaufs die
selber will ja man das richtig gute
logik und auf jeden fall so ein
richtiger mädchen trend 2017 richtig
fashion bio kaufen wenn leute mit ihren
grips
übertreiben ja aber das ist auch schon
2016 ja leute das hier ist das wo ich
glaube ich als erstes auch drauf
gekommen wäre jeweils shirt das hat auch
echt gefühlt jeder zweite mir geschickt
das bezieht sich natürlich auf jungs
trends auch an sich kann man erst mal
sagen super shirt ich finds auch gar
nicht hässlich das ding ist nur es ist
ähnlich wie bei alias super-stars das
hat einfach jeder ich glaube ich bin in
den letzten zwei monaten noch nie
rausgegangen und habe kein leser shirt
gesehen und ich weiß ja die hälfte von
euch hat seinen start ich habe übrigens
keines was mein bruder glaube ich weiß
was ich dann aber wiederum witzig finde
sind diese ganzen wie soll ich sagen
parodien von levi's shirts zum beispiel
beams oder so das habe ich auch schon
öfter mal gesehen am witzigsten finde
ich einfach penis weil jeweils penis
sieht ungefähr gleich aus von den
buchstaben beides fünf buchstaben
behindert oder auch elvis koopmann leber
ist besteht aus den gleichen buchstaben
wie elvis also man könnte das als
einfach nach vorne tun und hätte leser
ist also meiner meinung nach natürlich
zu die schweiz ein bisschen ausgelutscht
aber wenn man sich schön findet warum
sollte man sie nicht anziehen wenn ihr
glück habt dann bringe ich auch mal ein
leser draus und schreib einfach alex wie
drauf das wird auch fünf buchstaben so
die christina hat mir dieses foto
geschickt habe ich auf jeden fall in
letzter zeit jetzt auch öfter mal
gesehen
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das teil
nennen was man sich darüber auch
schneide ich finde das sieht etwas
brutal aus aber an sich ganz teils
hauptsache das ist nicht so ein ding ich
habe das auch mal gesehen dass tragen an
frauen und machen das jeden tag ein
bisschen enger damit die die taille oder
wie das heißt
damit das halt immer enger und enger
wird und man dann so aussieht wie sonne
sanduhr korsett
sie kostet korsett war dass das brauch
ich will jetzt nichts weiter sagen also
hier wurde so geschrieben oh mein gott
das ist so schlimm ist jetzt auch nicht
so mein lieblings modeaccessoire aber
jedem das seine
ok kommen wir zur nächsten sache wo ich
auch einfach mal sagen muss ähnlich wie
das netz hunde filter da hatte ich auch
irgendwann mal bei mir im video
instagram gewählte augenbrauen das haben
wir wirklich so viele geschickt und alle
haben sich übels oder aufgeregt bauer
das ist voll schlimm
die voll scheiße aus das macht jeder
alles sieht jetzt natürlich etwas
komisch aus aber jeder filter sieht in
gewisser weise komisch aus also da muss
man erstmal drauf kommen diesem filter
zu erfinden
irgendwie finde ich denn bei instagram
nicht so wo ich da jetzt aber auch mal
sagen muss das ist folgendes ja da habe
ich einmal dieses foto zu bekommen und
dann aber auch noch dieses foto hier
diesen trend sieht man vor allem auf
instagram mega auf der trend ist vor
allem der irgendwie seine augenbrauen zu
verfolgen wenn ich mir zum beispiel mal
meine augenbrauen angucke und mir dann
diese augenbrauen angucke irgendwie
besteht diese augenbraue aus 50h das
war's dann aber auch schon dann sind
haare nach unten kippen haare nach oben
gekämpft wie viele augenbrauen hast du
dir gezupft aber ich finde dieses
geschminkte augen das sticht fiel
mehrere also um mich da ist etwas
zurückzuhalten es ist auf jeden fall
sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig diese
wunderschöne hipster brille
ach so ja brillen tragen irgendwie alle
wobei ich da auch sagen muss natürlich
sagt er jeder von grund auf so erstmal
wie sie trägt jetzt eine brille der
braucht doch gar keine
ich finde es gibt leute denen steht so
was und es gibt leute denen steht so was
er nicht ich gehöre ganz klar zu den
leuten denen es nicht so steht aber ich
kenne auch recht viele mädchen getragen
aber zumal seine brille und das sieht
echt gut aus so leute nächste trend wo
sich auch drüber aufgeregt wurde ist
dieser hier und zwar haben wir hier ein
pulli
diese police kommen gerade in den trend
ist an sich kein polymer ja der pulli
ist halt zur hälfte auf geschnitten
damit man sieht was drunter ist also
erstmal muss ich sagen ich finde das
sieht richtig gut aus ich hab das jetzt
schon öfter mal gesehen und als das
erste mal gesagt dass er das macht ja
gar keinen sinn macht ja irgendwie auch
nicht da kommen wir aber gleich zur es
sieht echt cool aus was ich mich jetzt
nur frage temperaturbedingt sagen wir
jetzt mal das passt irgendwie überhaupt
nicht zusammen ich meine wir haben den
polit der ist oben total war und hier
total kalt das heißt man kann ich nicht
anziehen wenn es kalt ist man kann ihn
aber auch nicht anziehen wenn es warm
ist versteht ihr was ich meine
von daher macht halt irgendwie auf
dieser fashion seite sind das war es
aber auch also versteht ihr was ich
meine es macht ja nicht wirklich so sind
aber es sieht wohl auch so und dann
kommen wir zum letzten foto was mir
gerade noch heraus gesucht habe wenn es
halt irgendwann zu langweilig wird dass
man den bh unter dem t-shirt trägt trägt
man ihn jetzt einfach über dem t shirt
warum auch nicht und vor allem
unter rosen drauf oder was ist das ja
leute dazu schreibt jetzt alle macht
fleißig eure meinung in die kommentare
bei 10.000 likes gibt es an der nächsten
party von 2017 und sobald haben wir auch
schon 2018
die zeit geht so steckt auf jeden fall
was netz oder instagram vergess ich
meine letzten videos anzuschauen aber
nicht vergessen das habe ich auch schon
ewig nicht mehr gesagt und wir sehen uns
dann morgen wieder oder übermorgen
haut rein